good evening for those of you who are
sad I didn't show up to College GameDay
at the University of Central Florida
this week I need to remind you that my
home just burned down but let's discuss
my alma mater your soon-to-be
back-to-back national champions the
college football playoff committee hates
cinderella's but loves the ugly inbred
stepsisters like West Virginia Oh
UCF would lose every single game if they
played in the SEC get last season we
beat Auburn who's smoked Bama and
Georgia
despite being handicapped and I'm not
talking about our star safety playing
with one hand tied behind his back
figuratively I'm talking about the
interim coach we pawned off on Nebraska
the problem for UCF is that all their
boats are being tabulated in crooked
Florida I demand a recount
why even ranked non-power five teams
that they have no chance the pac-12
hasn't been relevant since that truth or
Pete Carroll was cheating and Notre Dame
isn't even in a conference no one under
90 cares about them except for priests
with some secrets it's 2018 can we write
off Michigan until they throw a forward
pass and quit making excuses for Ohio
State Urban spudsy memory may not recall
getting curb-stomp by unranked Perdue
but the rest of us do apologies to your
Buckeyes Herbstreit
I'd say what I really think but I'm
worried you'd exploit your kid and use
him as a human shield the state of
Florida is the most important state in
college football and the best team from
that state should get an automatic vid
and I'm including the phins bucks and
jagz savings invaluable eye for talent
is a joke
reminder he thought Drew Brees was
washed up in 2006 and tide fans try to
wrap your simple minds around this I get
paid more for making fun of Nick Saban
then he gets paid to be Nick Saban
just imagine what UCF could do if our
boosters could afford to pay five-star
recruits like everyone else
sorry we were founded in 1963 and not in
the 1800s like Alabama how about some
points for not taking a hundred years to
get good and allowing black people to
attend our campus from day one I don't
know that you see up a beat Bama in the
playoffs but we put up more
two field goals like Clemson I don't
even know if we have a kicker because we
haven't needed one in the last two years
if you don't believe me that's the
football-loving foodie who gives me all
my locks my special correspondent eat
deputy for 4-5 yo Daniel what's going on
what am I see the UCF Knights they'll
never get the goddamn respect that they
truly deserve regardless of him beating
Auburn who be Alabama
last year Kirk Herbstreit my missing
blond hair fake eminem lookin
still ain't giving UCF no
goddamn respect UCF isn't
gonna get on their hands and knees and
give these old-ass wrinkled white
the goddamn board saying
there is a path for UCF to make the
playoffs that's good enough for me
that's all for tonight Stosh point ot
special thanks to Colin Kaepernick's are
filling in on the B camera good night